- [Voiceover] What I wanna
do in this video is prove
that parallel lines have the same slope.
So let's draw some parallel lines here.
So, that's one line and then
let me draw another line
that is parallel to that.
I'm claiming that these
are parallel lines.
And now, I'm gonna draw
some transversals here.
So first let me draw a
horizontal transversal.
So, just like that.
And then let me do a vertical transversal.
So,
just like that.
And I'm assuming that the
green one is horizontal
and the blue one is vertical.
So we assume that they are
perpendicular to each other,
that these intersect at right angles.
And from this, I'm gonna figure out,
I'm gonna use some parallel
line angle properties
to establish that this triangle
and this triangle are similar
and then use that to establish
that both of these lines,
both of these yellow
lines have the same slope.
So actually let me label some points here.
So let's call that point
A, point B, point C,
point D, and point E.
So, let's see.
First of all we know that angle CED
is going to be congruent to angle AEB,
because they're both right angles.
So that's a right angle and
then that is a right angle
right over there.
We also know some things
about corresponding angles
for where our transversal
intersects parallel lines.
This angle corresponds
to this angle if we look
at the blue transversal as it
intersects those two lines.
And so they're going to
be, they're going to have
the same measure, they're
going to be congruent.
Now this angle on one side of this point B
is going to also be congruent to that,
because they are vertical angles.
We've seen that multiple times before.
And so we know that this angle, angle ABE
is congruent to angle ECD.
Sometimes this is called
alternate interior angles
of a transversal and parallel lines.
Well, if you look at triangle
CED and triangle ABE,
we see they already have
two angles in common,
so if they have two angles in common,
well, then their third
angle has to be in common.
So, because this third
angle's just gonna be
180 minus these other two,
and so this third angle
is just gonna be 180
minus this, the other two.
And so just like that, we
notice we have all three angles
are the same in both of these triangles,
well, they're not all the same,
but all of the corresponding angles,
I should say, are the same.
This blue angle has the same
measure as this blue angle,
this magenta angle has the same measure
as this magenta angle,
and then the other angles
are right angles, these
are right triangles here.
So we could say triangle AEB,
triangle AEB
is similar, similar
similar to triangle DEC,
triangle DEC
by, and we could say
by angle, angle, angle,
all the corresponding
angles are congruent,
so we are dealing with similar triangles.
And so we know similar
triangles are a ratio
of corresponding sides
are going to be the same.
So we could say that
the ratio of let's say
the ratio of BE, the ratio of
BE, let me write this down,
this is this side right
over here, the ratio of BE
to AE, to AE, to AE,
is going to be equal to, so
that side over that side,
well what is the corresponding side?
The corresponding side to BE is side CE.
So that's going to be the same
as the ratio between CE and DE, and DE.
And this just comes out of similar,
the similarity of the triangles, CE to DE.
So once again, once we established
these triangles are similar,
we can say the ratio
of corresponding sides
are going to be the same.
Now what is the ratio between BE and AE?
The ratio between BE and AE.
Well that is the slope of
this top line right over here.
We could say that's the slope of line AB,
slope of line connecting,
connecting
A to B.
All right, let me just use,
I could write it like this,
that is slope of, slope of A,
slope of line AB.
Remember slope is, when
you're going from A to B,
it's change in y over change in x.
So when you're going from A
to B, your change in x is AE,
and your change in y is BE, or EB,
however you want to refer to it.
So this right over here is change in y,
and this over here is change in x.
Well, now let's look at
this second expression
right over here, CE over DE, CE over DE.
Well, now, this is going to be change in y
over change in x between point C and D.
So this is, this right over
here, this is the slope of
line, of line CD.
And so just like that, by
establishing similarity,
we were able see the ratio
of corresponding sides are congruent,
which shows us that the
slopes of these two lines
are going to be the same.
And we are done.